soit les gens me trouvaient m6 tu
trouves une émission ou qui va vers les
gens mais pour moi le plateau j'y crois
pas d'accord alors moi je dis on est bel
et bon plein fils jean là parce que là
on va parler d'un sujet sérieux au plr
vous allez bonne riches aiment bien
sérieux messi est ce que vous aimez
stéphane plaza j'adore stéphane plaza et
j'adore son émission moi j'aime beaucoup
est ce que ça pourrait être votre style
si vous n'étiez pas etc roger bouka
alors que c'est pour moi le message
c'est lui le fameux qui avait alors je
vous dire stefana c'est ça et quelqu'un
que j'aime énormément il le sait c'était
le 19 novembre à vous est arrivé le 19
novembre c'était votre retour dans
l'émission ouais non ce pas un peu long
métrage entrer l'accusé là on est dans
l'amour personne n'est coupable là il
m'a mis j'ai toujours été raide dingue
amoureux delphine hall lé téléphone
parce que là j'y crois pas trop je vous
jure que c'est vrai non non non non mais
je dirais que c'est pour moi la plus
belle femme au monde
je lui donne tout même mon âme je peux
lui dire oui dit lui on peut le dire à
la france entière
un mot de sa part je traverse le monde
pour la retrouver
là je te kiffe à vie et pour la première
fois je suis jaloux de toi voilà il
habite à paris
c'est magnifique mais stéphane plaza a
vraiment un énorme crush poudmet matroni
chocolat est est bien sévère avec cvc
que tu lui envoies un texan en 2002 il
répond en 2000 je sais c'était en 2000
ça fait du teasing je suis ravi de
savoir que c'est plaza parce que j'aime
beaucoup ce qu'il fait et il savait t
mac lesggy aussi choisi je regardais
beaucoup quand j'étais petit je suis je
m'en moque et jan jambon
stéphane messi villa lui roger j avais
pas eu roger l'a rongé par la mer rouge
il est pas là moi je n'existe pas
matthieu rougé n'existe pas est ce que
vous recherchez un appartement ou une
maison de stéphane catta je recherche a
très souvent des appartements ou des
maisons donc pourquoi pas un jour je
dormais ce que j'en crois votre style
stéphane là il est sain il est pas mal
non il est très sympa et je trouve qu'il
est très spontanée j'aime beaucoup et
qui change en boudant mais stéphane
godreuil amoureux de vaud où est ce que
c'est parce que ça aurait pu et le ce
faire on pas du tout y'a pas roger mais
dans une autre vie tout est possible
d'accord dans une autre donc lacombe
revient pas là une erreur ça c'est moi
donc là je vais dire oui toi tu te
déplaces pour des fous rires non merde
avec la course à bercy mais sa
billetterie